as you can see we're still trying to
sort out even those basic facts of this
and as we are the usual forces of
division of tried to turn this into some
kind of identity politics form members
of Congress immediately demanded that
the White House classify the Gea's
killings as domestic terrorism they
suggested there were racial motivations
behind the bombings the truth is we
don't know that we don't know very much
at all at this point here are a few of
the unanswered questions still out there
first most obviously who is doing this
we have no name no face not even a
grainy photograph or a police sketch of
a suspect the attacker were attackers
remain totally mysterious we're not even
sure if it's a single person it could be
several it could be an organized effort
by a terror group it's also possible at
least one bomb was a copycat with a
package bomber switch to using trip
wires we don't know and what's the
motive no notes of surf there's no
manifesto to police think there's a
pattern to the attacks the first two
bombs went to black families in Austin
the third bomb injured a Hispanic woman
though apparently she was not the target
authorities say that bomb was addressed
to somebody else who was it addressed to
does that person have anything in common
with the first two people hurt by the
bombs what about the bombs the FedEx
facility today who are they addressed to
on Sunday a tripwire bomb hit a
completely different part of town and
injured two people who are white were
they targets does that mean race played
no role or a role that's more confusing
than we imagined motives in these cases
tend to be impossible to guess without
evidence the letters and stop people
from trying remember the Unabomber was
waging a one-man war against the
Industrial Revolution
that's not something FBI profilers would
have surmised or did and one of the
bombs themselves tell us is there a
pattern to their design do they bear any
resemblance to explosive used by terror
groups abroad two IEDs used in the
Middle East and last most important how
close are police to catching whoever is
doing this FedEx turned over an
unexploded bomb to police and police
believe they know where the bombs were
sent from will that lead anywhere we
don't know all of these questions need
to be answered none Durst in order to
understand the attacks their cause and
whether there are broader implications
for the rest of us but for now it seems
wiser
focus on answers rather than reaching
conclusions unsupported by evidence